[Music]  Rob Kardashian apologizes for his  social-media meltdown and it appears  black China has forgiven him over the  weekend Rob claimed fiance China left  him and took their daughter dream with  her and China took everything that we  built for the nursery for the baby dream  and she left and she just left me alone  Rob deleted the post but on Monday he  apologized riding this weekend I was in  an emotional bad place and did some  things that embarrass myself and my  family I'm seeking help to deal with my  flaws / issues the 29 year old went on  to praise China as a good mother to  their child Rob also shared this photo  of dream calling his daughter his life  and vowing to get better for her you are  my life and gave me a new start on being  a better me for her part it appears  China may have forgiven him she reposted  Rob's apology with a heart emojis  you